hello i'm james murphy and welcome to part
two of what's new coming in python 3.10.
in the last video i discussed everything relating
to type hints. in this video it's everything
else. most of what we'll cover in this video is
more or less just quality of life improvements,
but there are some new features. okay let's
get started. in my video on data classes,
the one thing that i said the data classes library
is lacking is support for the slots feature.
well, data classes now support slots. nice.
they can also now be pretty printed. as far
as quality of life improvements, here we go.
first up is parenthesized context managers.
you can now use parentheses to enclose context
managers which allows you to put them on multiple
different lines if you so choose. previously you
weren't able to do this because of limitations
of the parser, but in python 3.9 the parser
was actually updated to a new kind of parser.
the new parser is a little bit more robust from
the old one and it can now handle things like
this that the old one couldn't. this is especially
useful when you're using and capturing multiple
different context managers. if you had to
put all of these on the same line or use
line continuations this would be really annoying.
the next quality of life update is a whole bunch
of different better error messages. for instance,
if you forget a closing brace python will now tell
you that you didn't close the brace. i'm sure that
veteran python programmers are well aware of what
kinds of error messages you might have gotten if
you forgot to close a brace somewhere, but for new
python programmers something like this can really
make it easier to learn the language. it tells you
exactly what went wrong. it can now also tell you
about needing extra parentheses around generator
expressions and arguments, and it can tell you
if you forgot a colon say after an if statement.
i've definitely done this one, forgetting to put
parentheses around a tuple in a comprehension.
the previous error message was not so helpful. it
looks like this person pablo contributed basically
all these better error messages, so thank you
to pablo. did you forget a comma? did you forget
some parentheses? did you have a dictionary key
with no value? did you use a single equal sign
instead of two? i've never tried to do this but
apparently star expressions are not allowed in
f-strings, now i know. and the list keeps going.
better errors if your indentation is messed up,
and "did you mean..." suggestions for typos in
attributes or in names. i think these better error
messages are really going to help out newcomers.
on the other hand, pep 626 about precise line
numbers is going to help veterans alike. those
of you that have spent enough time debugging may
have noticed in the past that line numbers are
not exactly right all the time. i'm not exactly
sure what makes it happen, but it seems to crop up
in multi-line comprehensions and pass statements.
in any case, line numbers in debug statements
are going to be more precise in python 3.10.
here's a change that was really hidden in the
details. remember my video on how plus equals is
the sharpest corner in python? well apparently
power equals was a little bit sharper because
there was a bug in its implementation. power
equals will now behave the same as all other
augmented assignment operations like plus equals.
and as long as we're down here let's talk about
pep618: adding a strict flag to the zip function.
now you can pass strict equals true to a zip in
order to ensure that all of the iterables have the
same length. if they don't, it'll raise an error.
there are also some optimizations to existing
features in the language. the most notable one is
that they claim that constructing strings, bytes,
and byte arrays is now 30 to 40 percent faster.
i'm a little skeptical about that one. do some
performance tests and let me know what you find
in the comments. the last two things that i wanted
to talk about are two safety features that have
been added to python. python now requires a recent
version of openssl. i think this is a good thing,
i don't think you should be using any
kind of out-of-date cryptography software.
and the last thing that i wanted to mention
was the new optional encoding warning.
if you're reading or writing text files you
should pretty much always be using utf-8,
but in some operating systems this is not the
default and it is therefore also not the default
in python. this has previously been a huge source
of bugs where one person tries to write a file,
gives it to someone on a usb stick, who tries to
read the file, and it doesn't work. you can now
set this flag to true if you want a warning so
that you can see all the places in your codebase
where you don't specify an encoding
or that you're using a binary format.
alright that's pretty much the rest of the
stuff that stood out to me on the change log.
if you haven't already be sure to check out
my video on structural pattern matching,
that's really the big feature
that was introduced in 3.10.
otherwise, of course there's a huge amount of
things that changed that i didn't talk about.
let me know what your favorite is in the comments.
thanks for watching and see you next time!